I try to stay off a pornography man
that's one of my biggest arch-nemesis is
pornography why I hate to live with
these rich people for a while
speaking of pornography the dad used to
masturbate at night and I would sneak
out there in the kitchen this back when
the family had like a family computer
you know it was in one part of the house
right and he's over there just in the
glow of that screen row and that's back
when the monitors were big you know and
he's just over there just [ __ ]
looking for the devil and he ended up
getting divorced it was I think a lot of
it was because of that the worst is if
you're jerking off with a hat on bro
you're going to hell that's the most
French thing you can do straw Kentucky
Derby's you have to balance yourself
[ __ ] chimney sweep at the best be one
of those Chinese has broke if you squat
down low enough to the ground you can
almost hide under it in your feed oh
right the most confusing would be like
one of them Daniel Boone raccoon right
about to finish you distracted by the
tail
dusty [ __ ] fur and it's harder to
Jacqueline you're breathing out real
fast right yeah it's more of an intake
sport